let's go back to the phones by which i
mean
our discord voice server which you can
find at davidpakman.com
discord there are so many people uh
hoping to get on let's talk to
some of them why don't we go to ryan
from
dallas texas ryan you're on the air
hi david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
uh hi david um so you know i'm a young
black man and
you know i'm not i don't really consider
myself to be too liberal or conservative
i
kind of find myself in the middle okay
um and i and i don't really
like to cry wolf for every single issue
with the minority
i like to assess it based on
case-by-case basis but
my question for you is you know jim crow
only ended
56 years ago and there was there really
wasn't anything significantly done to
try to uplift
you know and compensate the black
community for all those years of uh
oppression yes and my question to you is
what do you think
should have been done and at the time
and what do you think we could do now
well the problem at the time was that as
we
have very much learned simply changing
the rules on paper
to outlaw certain types of
discrimination
it number one doesn't actually eliminate
the discrimination right away
and number two it doesn't actually set
people
up on an even playing field i've used
the monopoly analogy before uh
if a new player enters a monopoly game
after a few people have been playing for
an hour
on paper you can say everybody's playing
by the same rules but all the properties
have been purchased and the bank already
has relationships with the existing
players
etc okay that's the analogy so i think
that was the missed opportunity then
now i don't know if you're getting
towards the idea of
of reparations or not my thoughts on
this and people people get very angry
with me
some people get angry with me when i say
it but this is an issue i've looked into
to a significant degree i don't claim to
be an expert on it i have not
seen evidence that sort of throwing
money at people
is actually going to solve the issues
that remain as vestiges of the slavery
and jim crow
era throwing money at people won't solve
a lot of the geographic structural
issues that we have in terms of
neighborhoods and public transit and and
a lot of other different things it won't
at least not in any direct way solve
some of the education
inequalities that exist so i am open to
the idea
of a reparative process but i'm more
interested in seeing
how it can go to structural change
rather than necessarily like tossing
money at people
right i completely agree um i definitely
think that there needs to be a new
basic standard for you know i mean
simply stuff
stuff like apartments you know a lot of
these people are living in these
apartments that are just
or i mean just horrid apartments i i
used to live
in some terrible apartments rat infested
when i was when i was little so
and also schools you know they're so
underfunded and you have
these schools in the suburbs buying you
know new stadiums so i
i i'm completely on board with that now
let me ask you this you said that you're
not
super left or right what's an issue on
which you consider yourself a centrist
like is there a social
issue where you're a centrist um
for instance you know this bill that
came out about the equality act
you know i completely agree that there
needs to be some formal
you know um regulation on uh
not being discriminated because of your
gender identity and things like that
but like i don't agree with that gen you
know that they should be able to play in
the
sport that they identify with i guess i
guess in my opinion that's
being neutral but i don't now hold on
does that apply to all sports or only
certain sports
um i honestly haven't thought about it
that much um
you know i i i guess in my mind i would
initially think about
the more physically um you know
where you know where where your physical
um stature is more important and more
significant
but i guess i guess maybe it's just a
defense mechanism because i want people
to actually listen to me
versus just making assumptions about me
because you know i'm a young black guy
so it almost sounds like in a sense you
are taking some of these positions to
posture
as something other than a liberal
um maybe i i i
maybe that could be the case yeah i
would think about that i i definitely
don't think that i'm
i'm more liberal than conservative for
sure you don't think so or you are more
liberal than concerned no no i am
definitely more liberal than
conservatives i see yeah that's coming
through that's coming through yeah
all right my friend thank you for the
call i appreciate it all right thank you
all right take care
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an ebook
or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key
takeaways from the book just imagine how
you'll be able to expand your horizons
and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video